for the first time this season ladies
and gentlemen we are live
and say hi to our season 21 coaches i
see kelly clarkson
the great john legend
our newest
[Applause]
ariana grande channeled her inner jenna
rink from 13 going on 30 on monday
night's episode of the voice i like you
dress it's because they've got these
incredible boobs to fill it out
during season 21's first ever live show
ari whose love for jennifer gardner's
iconic rom-com is no secret took the
stage alongside fellow coaches kelly
clarkson blake shelton and john legend
rocking the famous multicolored versace
dress and pc updo from the flick you
know the one the dress jennifer rocks
during the thriller scene
[Music]
by the way ariana this is your first
live show yeah certainly how are you
feeling
i mean amazing it's so bad
[Applause]
it's so exciting it's so loud i can't
wait it's amazing the thank you next
singer also showed off the look on her
instagram story thanking the designer in
the caption and just for good measure
let's remember the time ari went full
jenna in her music video for thank you
next
[Music]
cause she grew from the drama
but back to the voice ari seems to be
having a blast on the hit nbc
competition show and when etie caught up
with the coaches at their preseason
press conference she said she's been
watching the show for years
i was a huge fan of the voice i have
watched many seasons and i love watching
the show it always has the best energy
and it's just such
like wholesome inspiring television and
i love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing and i've always been a fan
and that good energy has had the coaches
in their feels this season i know at the
very end like
what
okay
i know
this song means a lot to me my mom and i
would sing it together in the car all
the time
so what has the coaches feeling so
emotional here's what kelly and john
told e.t the artists are putting
themselves out there and they're really
connecting with the music and making us
really feel it we get to know them we
get to know their stories and get to
know why
those songs mean something to them and
why they connect with them and then of
course
particularly for ariana being a new
coach and falling in love with her
artists and then finding out she has to
send one home every time it's like it's
pretty tough and you can see how
emotional that is for her i know that
first season is really it's not that
it's any easier you're just at least
used to it and you start to like be okay
it's a game it's a game but it's hard
that first season
[Music]
you